continue place aux grands débats on va
justement pour suivre nos échanges sur
le contexte sanitaire qui va peut-être
un peu gâché nos vacances et notre
rentrée le rebond épidémique est très
clair pas de doute le variant delta fait
remonter les courbes le gouvernement est
en train de préparer les esprits à une
nouvelle vague peut être à de nouvelles
restrictions et peut-être à une
obligation vaccinale du moins pour les
soignants alors puisque c'était sujet
aujourd'hui entre jean castex et les
élus locaux
on va voir ce que donnait cette
rencontre avant d'en parler avec nos
invités c'est un sujet signé jérôme
ravier le gouvernement veut du consensus
sur la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants et il est en passe de
l'obtenir les principaux groupes
parlementaires à l'assemblée comme au
sénat y sont favorables
les professionnels de santé reçu hier
soir au ministère ont aussi livré un
message clair toutes les fédérations et
les autres qui étaient là ont signé
cette déclaration oui nous sommes tous
d'accord pour la rendre obligatoire
aujourd'hui le gouvernement continue
d'inciter à la vaccination avant sans
doute une phase plus contraignantes en
déplacement dans un centre de
vaccination olivier véran martèle que
c'est le seul et unique remède aux
restrictions tout le vaccin il les
protège à 95% des formes graves
par contre je les protège à 100% du
confinement c'est dire que si tout le
monde est vaccinée on n'aura plus à se
poser la question de savoir si nos
restaurants nos bars
nos commerces et des universités e
peuvent rester ouverte dans la durée
dernière étape de consultation une
visioconférence de jean castex avec les
associations d'élus qui soutiennent la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants et
pour certains il faut aller plus loin
c'est vaccination pour tous
voilà c'est tout est douce et sans
rechercher forcément une catégorie tôt
qu'une autre prioritaire un moment donné
il faut arrêter
forte de bricoler faut que faut que tout
le monde puisse effectivement se faire
vacciner
c'est désormais à l'exécutif de trancher
un conseil de défense se tiendra lundi
matin à l'elysée avant une prise de
parole des manuels macron d'ici au 14
juillet est avec nous pour le grand
débat d'elle pl ce soir andré grimaldi
bienvenue vous êtes professeur émérite
de diabétologie à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière à paris et vous êtes auteur
de ce livre santé urgences frédéric
bizarre face à vous bienvenue vous êtes
économiste spécialiste des questions de
protection sociale et de santé vous êtes
président d'instituts santé et auteur de
et alors la réforme blue globale de la
santé c'est pour quand pour
l'interrogation et je crois qu'en
octobre prochain vous publierez un autre
livre intitulé santé la seule réforme
possible
antoine thérain bienvenue chez directeur
général de la fédération des
établissements hospitaliers et des aides
à la personne et puis pas le casque y
ait également avec nous à distance
bienvenus vous êtes professeur de droit
public à l'université panthéon sorbonne
il y a globalement un consensus
politique sur le fait de rendre la
vaccination contre le coc vide
obligatoire pour les soignants mais
j'aimerais savoir si ce consensus est
aussi parmi vous ce soir paul cassia
obliger les soignants à se faire
vacciner contre le coc vide pas de
problème et je sais pas si si c'est
opportun de catégoriser comme ça une
partie de la population
moi je ne sais pas pourquoi on vise les
soignants il faut rappeler qu'il ira un
an les soignants épervier d'amateurs il
était considéré comme nos sauveurs
première ligne et comme il ya une
focalisation sur cette catégorie des
soignants qui doit à tout crasseux
contre une vaccination obligatoire mais
je ne comprends pas pourquoi cette
catégorie
deux français espagnol et lisez les
soignants ne sont pas plusieurs contacts
avec la population que par exemple des
enseignants que par exemple des
commerçants que par exemple un patron de
café alors pourquoi viser les soignants
qui diront pas construction se protège
et ont l'habitude de protéger leur
passion il ya ici une question qui se
pose aux réunions du principe d'égalité
traitement alors c'est intéressant parce
que vous nous dites un peu ce que nous
dit aussi l'association des maires
ruraux de france michel fournier qui dit
on cible plus particulièrement les
soignants mais pourquoi ne pas cibler
les gens qui reçoivent du public les
gens qui se retrouvent dans des
situations d'accueil professeur grimaldi
dont il ya une particularité et d'aidés
soignants c'est que vous confiez votre
santé avec personnel ça c'est pas à
aucun autre service public un camp je
vais j'ai un grand commerçant
je souhaite être en sécurité mais je
confie pas ma santé donc un problème de
confiance et la première règle éthique
pour tous les soignants et pour toutes
les personnes qui ont en charge les
personnes vulnérables
c'est ne pas nuire comment un soignant
peut penser qu'il a transmis une maladie
pas seulement le kobina une infection
nosocomiale
c'est un drame c'est un drame
professionnels donc sage merci d'une
d'une éthique professionnelle
il ya d'autres axes nation qui sera
obligatoire pour les soignants et que
pour les soignants donc évidemment c'est
autre chose à dire on veut éviter la 4e
vague ça concerne pas que les soignants
ça évidemment mais les soignants au
début ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu
ils se sont plaints de ne pas avoir
mesures barrières pas avoir les masques
et on les a applaudi parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas comme les autres d'ailleur
je rappelle que pour ce qu'elle est mais
ça c'est une profession assermentés j'ai
une personne vulnérable en face de moi
je ne traite pas comme un client je
dresse comme un patient et on pourrait
dire comme si c'était quelqu'un de ma
famille et je pense que la population
souhaite dire si je vais à l'hôpital
j'ai attrapé palco ville alors la
vaccination n'est pas une garantie à
100% il faut prendre toutes les mesures
mais la principale mesure barrière qu'on
a c'est la vaccination alors utilisons
frédéric bizarre cette vaccination
obligatoire qui se profile un très
clairement quand même si on écoute un
peu les discours politiques et ce
consensus politique des élus de tout le
monde
on va là une vaccination obligatoire des
soignants ça vous pose question vous
dites oui pour les soignants non pour
les autres oui pour tout le monde ou non
pour tous pour personne tant sur le plan
du principe moi je suis fermement opposé
à une obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants comme pour la population mais
c'est vrai qu'on est le seul pays au
monde à obliger à mettre en place cette
obligation vaccinale et aucun autre pays
au monde qui met en place cette
obligation vaccinale
quand vous dites qu'un consensus
politique c'est vrai mais il faut savoir
que c'est un consensus politique ce qui
représente un échec collectif qu est un
échec de santé publique c'est à dire que
la france son bon système hospitalo
centré sur le soin à n'a jamais
construit un système de santé publique
efficace la santé publique c'est pas
quelque chose de répressif
1 mais la france que ce soit pour les
cigarettes
que ce soit pour l'obligation vaccinale
c'est de la répression on met les
signares être le plus cher possible ce
qui est nécessaire mais pas suffisant
pour que on sait bien qui suit la
sociale plutôt défavorisés ils
n'arrivent plus à acheter des cigarettes
et les gilets jaunes et puis maintenant
on voit que les genres fume parce que
évidemment c'est c'est pas simplement
une affaire de répression donc cette vie
cette vision répressive de la santé
publique ne peut conduire qu'à un échec
la question de fond c'est donc
maintenant qu'on a cet échec là qu on
avait déjà constaté avant que j'avais
participé à un groupe de travail mis en
place par le ministre d'ailleurs avec
monsieur fisher qui est qui le menait
sur l'obligation vaccinale des ondes
quand on est passé de 3 ans vaccins et
est en fête et suggéré qu'il était
probablement nécessaire de mettre en
place cette obligation et c'est avec ce
n est qu il fallait déjà penser à la
sortie de cette obligation c'est à dire
à convaincre les individus qu'ils soient
soignants et non soignants qu'ils le
fassent de même et cinq ans et dans tous
les pays ne sais pas je fais faut quand
même avoir conscience que mais en fait
vous voyez que cet état il ya une
question culturelle il ya une question
politique
il faut mettre en place un système de
santé publie pas simplement un système
de soins d'accord alors c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites fait
beaucoup réagir antoine perrin oui
j'étais hier avec le ministre et je peux
vous dire que le
le débat que nous avons eu il y avait
tous les ordres professionnels et toutes
les fédérations et nous avons tenu à
ramener le débat sur des choses très
objective objectivement locaux vides
c'est grave on en est à plus de 111
milles morts
objectivement les formes graves ce sont
des personnes fragiles les personnes
malades les personnes âgées les
personnes ayant des comorbidités les
personnes ayant des handicaps a priori
vacciner dites moi si je me trompe mais
on est très grande majorité et ben pas
toujours il ya au minimum 20% de
personnes âgées à domicile qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et donc les formes graves
qui arrivent sont majoritairement chez
eux ces formes ces personnes fragiles où
se trouve-t-elle majoritairement elle se
retrouve à l'hôpital ou en établissement
ou dans des services mais accompagnés
par des professionnels et dans la
déclaration que nous avons signé hier
nous avons tenu à ne pas stigmatiser les
soignants et nous avons tenu à ce que
d'abord ce soit pas la conviction qu'on
y arrive
et encore du travail à faire conviction
pour amener les personnes fragiles qui
ne sont pas vaccinés à le devenir
conviction pour amener les
professionnels globalement de la santé
du soin et de l'accompagnement et les
aidant à se faire vacciner
et si on n'y arrive pas suffisamment
alors là oui obligation vaccinale mais
pas stigmatisant les soignants pour tous
les professionnels qui sont au contact
direct de ces personnes fragiles qui
feront les formes graves et qui pourront
en mourir et je suis pas forcément votre
avis sur le fait qu'on est le seul pays
à la hâte de voir a demandé l'obligation
en italie un professionnel qui refusent
de se faire vacciner
il est mis à pied au québec un
professionnel et des recours juridiques
d'ailleurs alex mais n'empêche que
l'arrêté c'est ça au québec un
professionnel qui refusent de se faire
vacciner doit se faire faire 3 pc à par
semaine donc cette obligation on en
vient de sonder exception sa veuve par
kelava 085 mais il n'empêche qu'on monte
ça monte et je serais pas étonné que
d'autres pays nous suivent
et cette obligation vaccinale comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur grimaldi sais pas
s'il ya des précédents
je vais précédent avec il ya cinq vaccin
pour le moment obligatoire pour les
polonais soignants ça ne pose aucun
problème
professeur grimaldi ensuite paul cassia
je ne vous oublie pas paul la santé
publique s'occupe des populations ce que
pensent des soignants et s'occupent
d'une personne et cette personne elle
dresse en confiance c'est à dire des
infections nosocomiales ça concerne pas
que le coc vite c'est un grand problème
en france c'est pas éthique tout
simplement pour un professionnel de
vouloir faire des soins d'une créé par
exemple 100 m des grands ce que j'ai
connu
donc il ya un rappel à l'ordre est
autrement si on veut pas ça améliorera
d'alger l'association les patients ou
les familles vont porter plainte pour
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
donc c'est pas un problème mais vous
avez raison il faut pas montrer du doigt
n'y a pas des bons et des mauvais s'agit
de convaincre les bouts de chansons et
610 messi sur lui alors je le ferai
c'est vrai donc un moment donné et ben
oui la liberté n est pas la liberté de
chacun il ya aussi à diverses et
collective qui passeront à lui verser
chacun un mois si je suis malade et
comme vous dites très bien il n'y a pas
que les gens âgés il ya les obèses les
diabétiques 4 millions il ya 200 mio
déprimé le vaccin c'est pas 100%
d'abord ils sont pas de sens vacciné
mais le vaccin n'est pas 100%
donc mettons toutes les mesures ensemble
enfin on fait société on n'est pas
seulement une somme d'individus on est
une collectivité dans l'es11 vaccins
obligatoires
ça a permis qu'il y ait moins
d'encéphalite de la rougeole il ya
encore des ya chaque année on a un gros
problème en france qui est là vous avez
raison de santé publique un défaut en
france historique
chaque année 10 h dans les ehpad des
gens qui meurent de la grippe alors que
le personnel n'est pas vaccinée en rayon
on n'a pas obligé donc je pense que lui
y aura d'ailleurs linverse non pas
transitoire mais à l'avenir face aux
crises à venir des obligations
vaccinales pour les soignants ont ça
fait partie des précautions qu'on doit
prendre il n'y a pas besoin c'est pas la
mairie
c'est pas une punition je ne suis pas
fier d'être vacciné enfin ses portes il
est encore vu mais c'est quand même un
peu surprenant paul cassia venant d'un
pays des libertés comme la france de
faire partie d d exception dans le monde
qui vont probablement rendre la
vaccination obligatoire
oui c'est qu'il faut concilier
effectivement la liberté le consentement
aux soins avec les impératifs de santé
publique donc il est tout à fait
possible d'imposer une obligation
vaccinale soit à toute la population
soit il particules fines sur le plan des
principes il n'y a aucune difficulté
sauf que s'agissant des vaccins
permettant de lutter contre le copinage
qu'il ya une particularité par rapport
aux accents obligatoire pour toute la
population et par rapport à ceux
spécifiquement vous d'accord pour les
soignants c'est que sauf erreur de ma
part c'est la chanson campagne
expérimentale ils n'ont pas encore eu
une ligne
une absence d'effets secondaires qui
histoire et prouver à l'instar des
vaccins ou aujourd'hui obligatoire
donc qu'est ce qui fait la différence et
qui pourrait faire douter de la légalité
d'une vaccination obligatoire mais ce
doute d'autres peut aussitôt à être levé
puisque en réalité ce débat a déjà eu
lieu
il a lieu personne ne s'en souvient mais
en décembre passé au moment de
l'adoption par le conseil des ministres
d'un projet de loi y pérenniser l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
bon on l'a oublié mais dans ce texte il
y avait un article qu'il permettait au
premier ministre de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire et aussitôt il
ya eu un tollé
tout à l'heure a été évoqué le consensus
actuel mais il ya six mois c'est un
consensus exactement inverse
il ya eu un tollé en défaveur de la
vaccination obligatoire qui a conduit à
un gel du projet de loi dans les 48
heures ce projet de loi n'a même pas
dupe et discuté à l'assemblée nationale
donc sur le terrain des principes encore
une fois il n'y a pas d'obstacle à une
vaccination générale cib et mais
s'agissant du duc au visage qui ne t'ont
pas le confondre complètement avec les
vaccins actuels puisque des batailles ne
sont pas encore sont encore en période
des fêtes petit lorsque occupy quitter
je vous laisse répondre professeur
grimaldi en avance juste après oui
deux remarques que moi également au
début je ne sais pas pour la vaccination
obligatoire
on l'a dit au choix niant effectivement
si vous êtes asymptomatiques vous mettez
les mains souvent et quand même
travaillé il ya une perte de confiance
vis-à-vis des autorités et même des
autorités sanitaires
donc mais maintenant le combat un recul
des trois milliards de doses utilisées
d'envoyer suffisant le recul oui il est
suffisant il est absolument suffisant
alors l'autre chose sur la santé
publique c'est que les anglais ont une
culture santé publique
ils sont massivement vacciner pour le
papillomavirus 1 il ya 80 % des
adolescents en angleterre qui sont
vaccinées en france et 20% ses 6000
cancer par an donc 3000 cancer du col de
l'utérus dont on aime nous un problème
qui est nouvelle nous avons des sciences
et vie de la prévention de la santé
publique et de vaccination alors il n'y
a pas que la vaccination obligatoire
qu'ils soient sur la table l'autre
petite musique qui monte c'est le retour
des restrictions c'est l'élargissement
du pass sanitaires à des lieux de vie
comme les restaurants c'est aussi le
déremboursement des tests pcr dits de
confort c'est même des contraintes à l'
isolement plus sévère bref lundi
prochain du conseil de défense
il pourrait sortir des mesures assez peu
réjouissantes pour les français disons
le pour l'ancien ministre stéphane le
foll
il ne faut pas en arriver là écoutez il
était l'invité de la matinale de public
sénat ce matin si l'objectif pour se
protéger c'est la vaccination c'est la
vaccination qui doit être la priorité
après si on commence à intégrer tout un
tas de contraintes
j'allais dire supplémentaires avec des
pass and it et obligatoire pour tel est
l activité géant va se compliquer la vie
là il faut se focaliser à lens ans sur
respect des gestes barrières dans tous
les lieux clos qui peuvent avoir des
conséquences en terme de circulation sur
le fait qu'on impose l'aération maximum
dans tous les lieux évidemment clos ça
c'est un point qui doit être aussi
rappelé et puis qu'on avance rapidement
sur la vaccination
frédéric bizarre d'abord moi je me suis
interrogé j'ai essayé de comprendre
pourquoi les gens ne se vaccinent est
passé en particulier les soignants parce
que je fais partie de ceux qui sont
farouchement pour la vaccination et qui
ne comprennent pas très bien comment les
gens refusent de vacciner bon mais se
moque de ce que je ce que je pense ou ce
qu on pense ici c'est un principe de
réalité
on a en france 40% de la population qui
est extrêmement méfiant vis-à-vis de la
vaccination et on a à peu près 50% des
aides soignantes 30 à 40 % des
infirmières et 20 % des médecins qui le
sont bon moi j'ai trouvé deux raisons la
première c'est que vous avez d'abord les
professionnels de santé sont au contact
des patients fatigués les patients qui
ont les effets secondaires dont qui
vivent beaucoup plus intensément ces
effets secondaires que sur des personnes
bien portantes que les autres donc ils
n'ont pas la même perception du rapport
bénéfice risque là la deuxième chose je
crois que ça a été dit dans votre
émission avant que en passant c'est un
anneau sur de défiance vis-à-vis des
institutions publiques ou on est dans un
système qui qui avec une telle crise
sociale notons pour s et qu'on peut
essayer de résoudre qu'en fait tout ce
qui vient des pouvoirs publics tout ce
qui vient d'en haut et vécu avec
beaucoup de défiance
rien n'est plus longtemps duré stage le
pasp le deuxième
autre point sur la crise mandji d'accord
avec monsieur loeffel faut peut-être se
poser la question de hocine pourquoi on
n'a pas réussi à accélérer
on n'a jamais été au dessus devrait de
600000 vaccinés par jour
je pense qu'il ya quand même eu d'aidé
des erreurs qui peuvent être corrigés je
pense que les professionnels de santé
qui n'ont pas été la première cible dans
la vaccination
moi j'avais recommandé six mois ça me
semble évident il fallait ce soir on a
préféré que ce soient les épate mon moi
je pense que provincial de santé devait
être la première cible
je pense qu'il faut c'est si vous faites
vacciner uniquement par les
professionnels de santé de ville plus
les hôpitaux pour les patients qui sont
dans les hôpitaux
vous faites sans problème de millions de
patients par jour
il ya cinquante cinq mille médecins
généralistes il ya quarante mille
pharmacien vous avez 115 mille
infirmières vous vous demandez à tous
les hôpitaux qui reçoivent des patients
c'est les cantons et dernier point les
hôpitaux
coty les insuffisants rénaux qui vont
dans un hôpital du manteau deux fois
deux fois par semaine
c'est con mais vaccine pas dans ceux
dans l'hôpital où ils vont on ne leur
propose pas la destination dans
l'hôpital où ils vont pas ce qu'on leur
dit vous allez dans le centre de
vaccination oui il ya tout un tas d une
organisation à roy parce que c'est cette
verticalité cette centralité de l'état
en france qui fait c'est pas une
question de ne pas des paliers au
pouvoir je pense que tout autre pouvoir
en place
mais voilà donc ça je pense que ça fait
partie du sujet antoine perrin oui je
pense que la défiance elle s'explique
aussi parce que nous sommes le pays du
sang contaminé nous sommes le pays de
l'encéphalite spongiforme bovine
nous sommes le pays du médiator nous
sommes le pays de de tout ce débat qui a
eu lieu sur l'hépatite b sur la sclérose
en plaques avant qu'il soit prouvé que
ce soit pas le cas et il ya une crainte
il ya une crainte par rapport à la
pharmacopée par rapport à tout ce qui
peut être apprendre à porter l'extérieur
et je pense qu'il faut convaincre le les
vaccins je suis un peu dans le temps
dans la contradiction avec ce que notre
juriste a dit ce n'est vaccin à rennes
message et ça fait 20 ans qu'ils sont
éprouvés en cancérologie on les connaît
les autres techniques de vaccination ça
fait ça fait des dizaines d'années donc
le recul on est là et là on sait que le
nos vaccins actuels même astrazeneca les
complications graves c'est 0,004 % très
bientôt à la vaccination antoine perrin
migrants bien
même tous ces gens ils resteront
vaccinés demain il y en a à peu près
pour un mois et demi puisque on compte
première injection quinze jours n'ont
même trois semaines quatre semaines
deuxième injection plus quinze jours le
gouvernement l'a doit-il prendre
d'autres mesures des restrictions
supérieur impasse sanitaire élargie est
ce que là dans l'urgence en attendant
que tout le monde se fassent vacciner
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin de
façon très objectif là où il ya un
risque
oui là où il ya un risque et lola là où
il le risque est mesuré
oui par exemple permettre les
regroupements sous condition d'un pass
sanitaire parce qu'on sait que dans le
regroupement il peut y avoir
transmission et lors le même avec le
masque le risque de transmission par le
vaillant delta et est majeur moi je suis
pas choqué qu'on demande impasse
sanitaires pour les regroupements que
toutes les boîtes de nuit qui rouvre
demain vu que c'est avec passé annie
terre ça va
moi je trouve que c'est une précaution
qui est nécessaire et responsabilisante
il faut être objectif sur l'effet sur
les dangers et sur les responsabilités
qu'on demande par contre rendre payant
dp tests pcr pour les personnes qui ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner et qui
veulent se faire sur et pâtasse pcr moi
je trouve ça normal c'est oui aussi à ça
je trouve pas ça choquant du tout au
fait ça mais je suis assez d'accord mais
tu peux pas vous laisser dire que les
les soignants voit les effets
secondaires des vaccins mais rien n'a
pas il voit les effets de la clique au
vide c'est sale qu'ils ont vu tous ils
ont pas vu les effets secondaires des
vaccins donc par contre les autres
raisons bien suivre et trop modique
pharma non mais soyons annonce à vue de
thrombose à 10 heures ils n'ont pas vu
00 longatte à l'espagne m'ont pas lui
paraît qu ils ont vu dans les journaux
et je suis assez vécu par contre ils ont
vécu je pouvais dire à saper triaire je
peux vous dire qu'ils ont vécu locaux
vides intensément et certains l'ont
attrapé il ya eu trente mille cas
d'infections nosocomiales locaux vides
depuis le début de la pandémie il ya eu
26 mille soignants qui ont attrapé le
coc vite dans l'or dans leurs hôpitaux
donc ça ils ont vu ils ont vu leurs
collègues alors
comme vous le dites ce big pharma créé
traumatisme y compris le fait que ce pas
un bien que le dic mondiale et ont dit
oui font de l'argent etc
la sphère du médiator évidemment et
c'est important qu'ils règnent frachon
est appelé à se faire vacciner
il ya aussi discours qu'ils entraînent
le juriste de l'hôpital si les
entreprises comme une autre bombe et ça
rentre dans les est maintenant à
l'hôpital c'est pas un truc est ce que
je me rappelle d'une banderole syndicale
vous y avez l'hôpital et à nous à
l'hôpital et pas aux soignants l'hôpital
et aux malades
notre but moi j'ai de moi tout ou
professionnel dans sa vie se dit est-ce
que j'ai pas fait une erreur et vous
pouvez transmettre accepté de
transmettre ce que vida quelqu'un donc
alors aprilia l'individuation de notre
société il ya moi je ma liberté passe
avant tout le reste et ça c'est pas
seulement les soignants c'est dans
l'ensemble de société c'est un vrai
problème est que les crises qui arrive
parce qu'à passer cette crise sanitaire
en annonce d'autres
1 et je crois qu'effectivement si on
peut pas faire l'obligation vaccinale
pour toute la population utilisé le pass
sanitaires vous avez un choix individuel
ne pouvait pas le genre payé par les
autres
vous allez au cinéma vous avez un pass à
l'inter mais par contre faut pas rendre
la vie quotidienne impossible pour aller
au au bar ou au restaurant ou au
coiffeur mais dans les lieux à risque
ben oui fois pas sony sympa sanitaire
qui pose encore des questions par donner
moins de liberté individuelle d'une
liberté publique on a eu plein de débats
paul cassia sur le sujet au départ et
c'est ça a été le cas c'était seulement
pour les rassemblements de plus de 1000
personnes aujourd'hui va finir par se
poser pour juste le restaurant alors
effectivement la pilule est une otage
qui peut être justifiée je ne ne
complète pas les éventuels délits fille
et je le suis pour les vaccinations dans
le principe mais on avait commencé à
dire que le pass anitea concernerait une
vive personnes qui s'avère aujourd'hui
qui seront applicables cette solitaire
puisque tel quel que soit le nombre de
personnes ils seront rassemblés
je ne suis pas en 3 opposé mais là là on
va de plus employé dans le grignotage
des libertés au nom de la protection de
la santé publique qui sert peut
satisfaire l'objectif de protection
descente de police pourquoi pas encore
c'est pas tellement la question je
voudrais simplement répondre à celles
que vous avez posé deux
question rêver car il tient à savoir
affi la vaccination obligatoire
justifierait que soit imposé des
réflexions supplémentaires et là je
voudrais dire qu'ils sont partir de
faits hawks et fils on peut pas dépendre
dans l'absolu à cette question il faudra
terminer comme ça a été dit il ya un an
quand les situations au cas par cas
y compris au plan local quel quel est le
taux de productivité des terres dans
telle région quel est le taux de
létalité dans telle région dont il me
faudra avoir un point de vue très char
de la question va pouvoir recommencer à
faire comme on l'a fait l'année dernière
c'est-à-dire les confinements des combos
et autres nationaux il fera perdre une
gestion fine et ça pourrait être la
contrepartie d'une généralisation de la
vaccination
mais avant la vaccination obligatoire
plus mécontents on a connu ça me
semblerait tout à fait disproportionnée
et je vous donne la parole dans un
instant fredrik bizarre mais je voudrais
qu'on regarde un autre exemple européen
un coup regarde du côté du royaume-uni à
une stratégie qui est un petit peu
nouvelle et peut-être intéressant vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
boris johnson a décidé de ne rien
changer à son programme de déconfinement
il annonce même un jour de la liberté
pour le 19 juillet c'est à dire que dans
11 jours
c'est la fin du masque en intérieur et
la fin des restrictions et c'est une
stratégie qu'il assume et qu'il explique
écoutez nous essayons de passer d'un
système de règles gouvernementales très
élaboré un système dans lequel nous
comptons sur les gens pour qu'ils
exercent leurs responsabilités
personnelles et suivent les conseils
conscient que comme je les dis cette
pandémie est loin d'être terminée il
faut compter sur les gens frédéric
bizarre c'est ce que vous souhaiteriez
oui mais c'est pas le même contexte un
il ya le taux de vaccination est
beaucoup plus élevé windows et avec la
sénégal contacts culturels mais ce qui
est intéressant dans l'approché anglais
c'est l'essai qu'il ya une stratégie
narnia une stratégie qui est
véritablement après avoir vacciné
scission à 65% 110% de pas sur la
première dose ont moins
maintenant voilà on considère que les
non vaccinés non pas à empêcher les
vaccinés véritablement de pouvoir vivre
normalement et tant pis si à quelques
dégâts collatéraux il en matinée c est
compter sur une pression de deux sortes
pour que les non vaccinés se fassent
vacciner bon c'est une stratégie la
stratégie en nous je pense qu'on est
tous d'accord ici pour dire qu'il faut
des mesures ciblées c'était très bien
dit avant d'abord pour des questions
d'acceptabilité par la population je
pense qu'aujourd'hui si on commençait à
confiner un peu un peu plus dur je pense
pas que la population n'accepterait le
seul problème c'est on revient à ce que
j'étais apte à lire cette centralité
cette verticalité de l'état c'est qu'on
appelle la gouvernance pour faire ça
parce que pour avoir des mesures ciblées
localement et autres il faut avoir une
politique très décentralisé fois vers
une gouvernance très décentralisé être
capable de remonter les données en temps
réel de chaque territoire de santé et
c'est ce qu'on est absolument incapable
de faire des arn juste aller il fallait
fermer l'agencé reste pas les outils
pour faire des aurès et ont été créés là
pour s'occuper des réseaux de
professionnels de santé absolument pas
pour gérer et on a à peu près rien
changé aux ars aujourd'hui on n'a pas
créé de cellule de crise on leur a pas
donné de au sein des rs on a bien une
réforme en cours un cas en discussion au
sénat notamment ça peut changer
non enfin on les renforce dans les
départements ce qui est bon c'est pas le
sujet antoine perrin oui
boris johnson a prononcé le mot
responsabilité en responsabilité et si
par la responsabilité on arrive à
avancer et je pense qu'il ya encore des
marches on peut le faire
la vaccination obligatoire ne sera pas
nécessaire et donc on a encore un peu de
temps mais par contre cette
responsabilité il faut que les citoyens
exercent et il faut par la conviction et
tous les citoyens à risque ou à risque
de transmettre
donc tous ceux qui sont autour pas
simplement les soigner encore une fois
des personnes les plus fragiles malades
ou en perte d'autonomie
les aidants en responsabilité est ce que
c'est normal qu'une personne puisse
rendre visite à une quelqu'un à
l'hôpital sans pass sanitaires je
poserai la question
elle pourrait contaminer et la
contamination ne vient pas que des
soignants et donc il ya vraiment un
travail de conviction très important à
faire
et je pense qu'il faut le continuer
alors il yal sur cette stratégie de
boris johnson ya un journaliste
politique que vous connaissez peut-être
renaud pila de lci il a fait une analyse
assez intéressante avec ses mots à lui
sur twitter je le cite et je vous fait
réagir professeur grimaldi
boris johnson optent pour la stratégie
non vaccinés démerdez vous malgré la
flambée épidémique il va lever toutes
les restrictions et compte sur une forme
de pression sociale pour que chaque
britannique aillent se faire vacciner
c'est exactement ça oui mais il faut
mais sans conteste c'est cela me ferait
bizarre c'est à dire que les anglais
sont beaucoup plus accéder ils ont pris
une stratégie avec une seule dose à
l'utiliser que si on vaccine toute la
population avec une dose on l'a en effet
cumulatif qui est plus important que
vacciner peut avec des théories
finalement c'était gagné l'an passé les
gagner du temps c'est un pari risqué et
je pense qu'en france on a bien fait de
pas le faire parce que là on aurait eu
beaucoup moins de vacciner et
partiellement vacciner seulement
donc après on dit bah il ya une pression
fantastique vous ai dit tout à l'heure
pour d'autres vaccins est les valises il
ya une tradition de la vaccination en
angleterre qui a pas en france de
manière à justifier alors il ya une des
raisons qui effectivement si on veut
faire une politique décentralisée adapté
au terrain ça suppose une
décentralisation du système de santé un
véritable système de santé public qu'on
n'a pas vraiment sur la santé des
populations
il ya qu à voir d'ailleurs y compris le
président a nommé un conseil
scientifique alors que you on a un haut
comité de santé publique dont c'était
fort c'est la mission officielle
donc on est dans une adaptation à la
crise alors maintenant le virus faut
comprendre aussi pourquoi les normes
changent mais les normes changent parce
que le virus change et le plus
contagieux chaque fois prend le dessus
donc quand on essaie à ce qu'on appelle
à 1 023 en mai 0,2 si c'était à
contamine beaucoup plus et ben du coup
on est obligé de dire bat pour obtenir
l'immunité collective il faut monter la
barre pour assurer la balle là le pass
dans une activité commune
la jauge sera plus serrée 1 donc alors
peut-être qu'un jour on aura un vaccin
un virus très contagieux et à cebenna si
tout le monde fait un gros rhume sera
urgente à vacciner pour le moment ce
n'est pas le cas pour lancer pas le cas
on a vu ce qui se passe en inde lors d
un débat un peu de pays riches à ce
musicien en tunisie les vidéos que je
reçois de mes collègues on trouve à
notre débat un peu surréaliste ils
attendent ils attendent que ça bon en
même temps le grand paradoxe parce que
gilles respecte pas non plus l'usure
d'ailleurs mais en même temps c'est des
services de réanimation sont totalement
débordés
il nous reste moins d'une minute
peut-être pour conclure paul cassia et
s'il vous reste une seconde aujourd'hui
dix amants moi je le tweet que vous avez
cités par de flamber et fille des vidéos
moi je crois qu'il faut raison garder je
parle sous le contrôle de votre invité
suspect fini le riche d'un médecin mais
je ne crois pas qu'on en soit là donc il
faut il faut il faut raison garder moi
je suis plutôt pour la citation que
l'obligation
je rappelle qu'il y a il ya quelques je
rappelle qu'il y a quelques semaines
seulement le président de la république
avait indiqué qu'il était opposé à une
vaccination obligatoire pour toute la
population
alors comment se fait-il qu'on est un
poile a battu les et s'agissant des
mesures ciblées je pense qu'on peut
faire dans la dentelle
est ce qu'il ya des préfectures qui sont
en charge de cela c'est ce qui a été
fait à certains moments dans la période
récente il est tout à fait possible buzz
territoire par territoire ciblé des
mesures spécifiques qui permettent de
lutter plus efficacement contre la
diffusion du virus il ya une légère
nationale qui fait la pêche au chalut et
ce sera la conclusion de ce débat merci
merci pas le cas c'est à merci beaucoup
à tous d'avoir participé aux grands
débats et le ps et donc la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent lundi
à 18 heures et à 22 heures demain matin
7h30 bonjour chez vous rien en chimie
recevra notamment stanislas guerrini
délégué général de la république en
marche je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée
[Musique]